cuáles de los siguientes triángulos son
similares al triángulo abc nos dan todas
estas opciones y veamos ese es el
triángulo que nos preguntan cuáles de
estas opciones son similares a este abc
recordemos a qué nos referimos con
triángulos similares si yo tengo dos
triángulos por ejemplo este de acá y
tengo otro triángulo más o menos
y me quedo un poco chico el espacio pero
bueno si yo tengo estos dos triángulos
que se ven a primera vista pues
diferentes este es más grande que este
dos triángulos serán similares si y sólo
si todos los ángulos internos
correspondientes son iguales o
congruentes qué quiere decir que si
tengo este ángulo de acá y es igual a
este ángulo de acá y además tengo este
ángulo de acá igual a este ángulo de acá
y finalmente este ángulo de acá es igual
a este ángulo de acá
todos los ángulos internos
correspondientes son congruentes
entonces estos dos triángulos van a ser
similares similares cuando tenemos
triángulos similares la proporción de
los lados van a ser iguales entre sí
imaginen que este lado de acá en este
lado de acá que estoy señalando en rosa
mide 2 y el lado de aquí abajito este de
aquí mide 1 bueno esta proporción 2 a 1
de este triángulo también se va a tener
en este tengo lo más grande supongamos
que este lado de acá que estoy señalando
mide 3 y el lado correspondiente aquí
abajo este de acá mide 1.5 sigue siendo
la misma proporción 2 a 1 así que estos
dos son similares sus ángulos internos
correspondientes son iguales
y la proporción entre sus lados también
va a ser igual bueno ya que recordamos
esto ahora vamos a ver lo aplicada acá y
analizando cada una de estas opciones
veamos nuestra primera opción es el
triángulo a head vamos a marcarlo
el triángulo a g d
bueno pues de entrada podemos ver que
estos dos triángulos son similares de
hecho comparten dos lados o sea esta
hipotenusa y este lado y bueno vemos que
este otro lado es paralelo a este
entonces esos triángulos si son
similares esta opción si es ahora veamos
la siguiente c
efe vamos a marcarlo en otro color
hasta acá efe bueno ese triángulo no es
similar porque recordemos que la
pendiente de una recta va a ser
constante y cualquier triángulo
rectángulo que se forme con cualquier
par de puntos sobre esta recta va a
tener la misma proporción es decir
también va a tener la misma pendiente
recordemos que la pendiente es la
diferencia en ye con respecto a la
diferencia en x nuestros triángulos abc
este es un triángulo rectángulo aquí hay
un ángulo recto este otro la opción que
vimos a gd también lo es esta línea es
perfectamente horizontal y este x
perfectamente vertical pero esta c
efe aquí no tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo este es un ángulo que se nota
que es mayor al 90 grados así que aquí
no hay similitud este no
vamos a siguiente sé de qué se dé
este de acá este de acá y este de acá y
pues lo mismo que en el anterior caso no
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo aquí
esta línea no es para nada vertical así
que este es un ángulo menor a 90 grados
y aquí tampoco va a aplicar la similitud
veamos la tercera opción triángulo d
efe veamos d es un punto que está aquí
sobre la línea y esta es una línea
vertical por completo efe
y a esa línea es horizontal así que en
este triángulo de acá si se está
formando un ángulo recto acá de 90
grados
y tenemos dos puntos que están sobre
esta línea cuya pendiente es constante
entonces este triangulito de aquí es
similar a este triángulo de acá y a este
que nos indicaban originalmente este si
cumple con las reglas de similitud de
todas maneras vamos a recordar un poco
de las clases de álgebra sobre las
líneas paralelas y las transversales por
ejemplo esta línea de acabe el segmento
d
que lo voy a hacer un poquito más grande
de aquí acá esta línea la podemos ver
como línea paralela al segmento ave o
incluso al segmento ag la voy a marcar
también aquí de aquí acá las extiendo
para que se note que son líneas
paralelas
y podemos ver esta línea en nuestra
línea recta azul como una transversal a
estas líneas paralelas y recordemos que
los ángulos que se forman en líneas
paralelas por una transversal van a ser
ángulos iguales así que el ángulo
formado entre esta línea y esta es igual
al ángulo formado entre esta línea y
esta estos dos son iguales de hecho le
pongo doble marca para que se note que
son iguales estos dos lo mismo de este
otro lado si yo tengo esta línea de acá
que incluye el segmento efe la voy a
extender en esta línea así y esta otra
línea del segmento bc de aquí acá
estas son líneas paralelas y de nuevo mi
recta es la transversal así que el
ángulo que se forma entre estas líneas
paralelas azules y esta transversal va a
tener la misma medida entonces este
ángulo de acá que le pongo con tres
marquitas es igual a este ángulo de acá
con tres marcas y bueno ya habíamos
quedado que estas becas son ángulos
rectos y este de acá y este de que
apenas se nota así que éstos tienen
ángulos internos correspondientes
iguales por lo tanto son triángulos
similares ahora veamos si esto es la
respuesta correcta ok aquí está la
pantalla en el portal de khan academy de
ejercicios de esta sección y
seleccionamos esta primera opción y la
última opción que eran las que nosotros
encontramos como correctas estas dos y
ahora veamos si de verdad estuvo bien
nuestro análisis
con probar respuestas y carita feliz muy
bien eso estuvo bien realizado nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo